Jesse James Decker's four-year-old just
leaked the unthinkable trying to keep it
together we are too because her
four-year-old son just accidentally
posted a pic of his dad Eric Decker in
the buff oh my God it's awful it's awful
it may look like an innocent selfie of
the couple's son Forest grinning but if
you take a closer look you'll see Eric
in the background showering yikes talk
about a parent's worst nightmare even
worse Forrest shared the pic with Eric's
Instagram followers luckily Jesse's
friend quickly flagged the mishap
texting the singer a screenshot of the
post which had already racked up over
800 likes in 8 minutes still they
couldn't contain their laughter Jesse's
pal writing I'm not even sure if you
know he has his phone but if you don't
know go grab but Jesse like this is a
disaster yep safe to say you can't trust
a four-year-old with your phone but Eric
was a good sport about it after deleting
the post he he called out the incident
on his Instagram story joking time to
change the code apparently Eric has
learned his lesson don't let your kid
play on your phone while you shower or
you could wind up in this predicament
you can only blame yourself of course
Jesse and Eric don't normally share it
not safe for work content but they're
all about gushing over their love the
country singer even dedicated her song I
do to her husband the music video
featuring shots from their 2013 wedding
day
[Music]
and Jesse and Eric told ET back in April
they even got matching ink to solidify
their Eternal Bond now accessories do
you have a nice ring on this TV perhaps
oh is that right you guys have got a new
tattoo oh my gosh
JD she put her not his ring so I talked
to him a second oh and when ET sat down
with Jesse at her tour rehearsal in
April she shared this sweet gesture from
her man proving Eric knows how to keep
the romance alive I woke up to this big
bouquet of roses from him and flowers
are beautiful and I was not expecting I
was like oh my God you're so sweet that
she like acknowledged it we're very
lucky to have found each other
foreign